uh thank you for being here
and
i feel
a bit tired it was a good day so i had
to concentrate a lot so i hope it will
not be
unbearable
and
so i'm going to talk about expanders and
about monotone expanders
and
and i i didn't know
before alexandra started talking i had a
different
introduction i explained a few things
now i
wrote this slide
and so
expanders
are graphs
and
we have good motivation to study them
and there are a few ways to define them
and i will just start
now
with what with what i will call expanded
in this talk it's a bit different
because i will consider the bipartite
case
so expander will be just a bipartite
graph
and
such that the both of its sides will
have size n
there will be two sides a and b
the finite sets
and
for every set on the left
that is not too large
the neighborhood
on the right is a bit louder
so this is a
the formal definition
of an expander
i guess
all of you have seen this at some point
and
because
they are so nice
we would like to understand expanders
and
so
i will give some background about
expanders and then say
what do i mean by understanding so there
are two ques basic questions one is
are there expanders and the other is can
we build expanders and we know the
answers to these questions so pins can
show that most graphs are expanders
and
this was
a long time ago
and
as time passed we also learned how to
build these graphs so the first
construction was using
a group theory
and
malgolis and gabaran galil
showed that
you can build a very simple graph the
vertex set
is the torus n by n
and the edges are defined by very simple
affine maps
like x y is connected to x and x plus y
and things like that
and this graph is an expander
and this follows because
there is a big group in the background
that has
good properties property t in this case
so it's group theory
and
another construction which is a
i think more delicate analysis somehow
is based on number theory
and
this construction gives a construct a
you take the cyclic group with p element
and you define the edges by simple
algebraic maps
and so you can construct expander in
this way
and so we have group theory number
theory and there are also iterative ways
to construct expanders this is the
zigzag product for example
and which basically takes two graphs
that are expanders and builds
a bigger expander
so we have ways to const to construct
these graphs
and there are more
um
and
i think
a legitimate question is how simple can
these graphs be
and so there are a few ways to answer
this so in some sense they are very
simple because basically all the graphs
are expanded
and
another statement uh which one proved is
that expanded graphs cannot be planar
graphs so they cannot they are not too
simple in this way
another statement of
that club approved is that you cannot do
a one-dimensional construction that is
analogous to this margolis
two-dimensional construction
maybe i will talk about it in the end a
little bit more what do you mean
yeah you can't do a one-dimensional
construction using a fine maps or even
slightly more general statement maybe i
will talk about it at the end
so they cannot they cannot be too simple
in this sense
and
another meaning of simple is can you put
them
in a book with few pages this is a
i will define this format in a bit so
this is another way to
um to address the simplicity and
the last
question is do we have monotone
expanders and i will both of these
notions i will now define
so i will start with
defining this constant page graphs
so
a constant page graph you can think of
the vertices as being on a spine of the
book spine i think it's called
and you can think of the edges as drawn
on the pages so here i drew the edges on
one page and the restriction is that the
drawing is like this the edges are not
allowed to cross each other
when you draw them so this is a one page
graph
this is a two-page graph
so you can add more pages to the book
and you get
a constantly many pages it's
or they clear be two circles within one
person
yeah they don't have to be nice
oh yeah
you can have another edge here if you
want
and
so these are constant page graphs these
are simple graphs because they fit in a
small book
and
it's some generalization of planarity
this is right and another motivation to
study these is
uh they are related to some turing
machines
and their simulations i will not talk
about this much
or at all
so these are constant page graphs
another so these are
this is a simple family of graphs
another simple family of graphs is
monotone graphs
a monotone graph will be
a in this token by partite graph again
and so now again we have two sets
but now these two sets you can think
about it
about these two sets as integers from 1
to n and the integers are ordered
1 is smaller than 2 and so forth
and you can define the graph or the
edges of the graph using
d monotone maps so
these maps need to be monotone so they
respect the order on n
and
if you try to do a full um
a map that is defined on all of a that
is monotone
there is only one
basically one such map which is the
identity map otherwise there are
collisions
if you want strict monotonicity
um so you make you may allow them to be
partial so they are not necessarily
defined on all of a but just on some
subset of a
so here is an example of
a
edges
defined by one monotone map this is a
this is b and these are
say if
one is mapped to two two is mapped to
four
and so forth
and you can add more layers so this is
another monotone map
each layer separately is very very
simple but the overall structure can be
fairly complicated
so these are monotone graphs they are
finite union of simple matchings
and
okay so we have
constant page and d monotone
so the definition is uh
is like this
if you have
if x is smaller than y then f is either
increasing or decreasing because in this
definition it has to be increasing right
it doesn't make sense
yeah
but in that case the vertex number n can
be mapped only to n right
just bigger than that
no it could be mapped to n over two for
example okay okay
this is the reason to allow the partial
yes good
so a
simple
observation is that
the monotone graphs are
constant page graphs so here is a this
was
proved by
zav and avi and it's a if you draw it
it's fairly simple you put here a
monotone graph and here a page graph so
what it had what happened this moved
here
and the upper side moved to the right
but was flipped
and
so
this matching became this thing
and this matching became this thing
and
we have now a two-page graph from a two
monotone expander
so this is general
and
so
page graphs are
more general
than monotone graphs
and
what i will try to tell you today the
how to build these
monotone graphs with a constant degree
with a constant number of generating
functions
and as a corollary as we said before
there are also
constant page graphs
and maybe i would say one way to try to
build these graphs is to take random
graphs random graphs are
good expanders maybe take a random
monotone graph it will be a good
expander
it's not completely clear what does a
random monotone graph mean
or
it could mean many things
but if you take some natural
distribution on a random matching just
one matching then it is quite
close to being a linear map every point
is mapped to some say
every x is mapped to 2x roughly or
something like this
and
so natural distribution give you maps
that are close to being a fine and such
graphs cannot be expanded this is what
clover proved so
i don't know of any
probabilistic construction of these
of these graphs and if you want to do
this it requires some
clever choice of a distribution
um
and another
comment that is maybe related a bit to
motivation
is that
from
monotone expanders you can get another
object which is called
dimension expanders
so do you have questions you're very
quiet
yeah i will do it in the next slide yes
yes this is
this already viren spiel car they built
the dimension expander but it was
actually a monotone
so yeah
yes
so who introduced these things
so as far as i know we started with this
dimension expanders actually
which i will define in a bit
and
i'm not sure who actually asked about
these things
some attempts uh well it doesn't matter
we have the submarine with the mirror
speed kinds there we asked this question
and eventually
we
gave it some and village pilka
uh
implicitly defined you know shoulder
reduction common correspondence and
again sort of medical expression
yeah in in their paperwork they haven't
spilled
implicitly used the notion of the
monotone expander
and later
burgund observed that this is actually
the property they used and
this was the way it was defined
so okay so i want to explain what are
the dimension expanders
and
these are
in
in short it's in briefly it's a they're
a generalization of expanders in what
sense
so here we will have a some vector space
f is
any field
and you look on the
n-dimensional vector of space over the
field and we want to find a constant
number of linear maps
l1 up to ld from the field from the
vector space to itself
and you can think about them as being
invertible n by n matrices
and you want the property that if you
choose any subspace v
of f to the n with not large enough
dimension
and then if you apply all of them on v
you get
few vector spaces you take all of them
together you get slightly larger
dimension
plus some
absolute constant
so this is a dimension expander
it sort of generalizes the notion of
expander
in some way
and but it's
not not a
these matrices are not necessarily
graphs so it's not directly expanded
but it's it's a natural generalization
somehow
the optimal one i have no idea
um
you measure the dimension of the reunion
it's a strange
i don't know but
it's not clear to me even how to define
it now
okay so
there may be a optimal
is
so yeah you can ask what is the given d
what is the maximal c you can achieve
and i don't know the answer
one plus c it depends how we measure
okay so these are dimensional expanders
and
i want to mention that over the real
numbers
uh lubotsky and zelmanov showed that
basically many construction of
real expanded graphs not dimension
expanders
that we know actually yield
um dimension expanders and
no it's it's related how to the how you
build the expander
and so it doesn't
um
like what is where you just need to act
by one subspace to increase like for
every v there is a single li which
increases the dimension
it's a it's equivalent if d and c
are constant
just
and
so over the real numbers we know of such
things and the observation that was
implicit in
the virulent spielker
is that if you have a monotone expander
you can very easily build from it a
dimension expander
and
i i will not explain this but it's very
simple it's an excellent sequel
this dimension explains the random set
of linear maps of this property yes yes
the question is about construction like
uh yeah but i mean i guess maybe
the natural notion of
management would be what's uh to achieve
the random number yeah yes
what is what is no i don't
you know
no may depend on the field
yeah but it's true for everything that
random ones are good like 100.
and okay so we defined what our
d-page graph monotone graphs
and
monotone expanders and these dimension
expanders
and now i want to talk to uh try to
explain how to build these graphs
and
we will have four parts to the
presentation
and first i will
say what are trial diagrams
these are ways to define graphs from
group actions
and then
we'll discuss a continuous version of
an expander
this will be useful for us
then i will tell you exactly what are
the choices that are made
in the construction and then i will try
to explain a little bit
about how you prove this
um
okay so let's start by the basic object
these are schreier diagrams
so a schwa diagram is a graph
and it represents the action of a group
g
on a set x and and there is some
finite subset of the group
that we
choose and they will define the edges
so a group action
is familiar
so yeah so
the way you define it it's very simple
in this case i will do a make it a
bipartite graph so on both sides you you
put the set x on which the group g acts
and the edges you connect a point x
to a point g of x
where g is some element of s
or
if s is symmetric
so
this is
a very
natural way to visualize an action you
just draw what it does
um
and so here is a ah
maybe a more familiar notion is
kaylee graphs this is when g acts on
itself then it's called the kale graph
and here is an example
of a schreier diagram
so the group
will be a group of two by two matrices
with determinant one over a finite field
there are roughly p to the power of
three elements in this group
and
the finite subset will be these two
matrices
and also the
inverses
and the action will be
the mobius section
on the line
which is a
the line is roughly p points on it and
this is the way the action is defined
it's called the mobius action the point
x when you act with a matrix g of this
form is mapped to this point and if you
divide by zero you get infinity and vice
versa
so this is indeed a goof action are you
not
prove it now
so
now we get a graph what what is this
graph
it has
roughly
the size of the graph is 2 p plus 1 on
the right hand side we have p plus one
and the right hand side we have p plus
one it's four regular we have s of size
two
so the graph in the graph you don't see
the group where it came from it's a
smaller object and but the group is much
larger than the graph it's
of size p to the power
so here this is an example
of a schreier diagram
and
so
okay so this is the first part what are
schreier diagrams it's clear
yes
take it easy yes
and
the next part of the construction is a
what are continuous graphs for us
so a continuous graph
it will be
exactly the same as
a
usual exp
by parallel graphs
but the set of vertices will be the
interval
the interval 0 1
and now the maps are maps defined over
the interval so they will be very smooth
as smooth as you want
and monotone with respect to the order
of the interval
and
there will be an expansion property the
expansion properties with respect to the
beg measure on this interval
so it's exactly the same except that's
from instead of endpoints we have more
points
okay so this is clear
so this is a continuous monotone
expander
and
why is this thing useful uh
it's useful because of
the following simple observation
if you take
the interval 0 1
this is 0 1 and partition it to interval
of length one over n consecutively
then you can round
the continuous object to a finite object
and if the continuous object is a an
expander also the finite object
will be an expander
and and this is the way you do it
say you partition the left hand side to
these n interval and the right hand side
to these
an interval
and you connect interval a j to b k
if
the map
c of i
acting on a of j this is
say an interval on the right hand side
intersect the interval bk
so
you just do the natural thing
you look what happens here if it touches
you connect
a i and j in the discrete
object and
so it's
it's simple to see that if the original
thing was an expander this one is also
um
these smooth maps they do not have to
have gradients at least one
they do not have you do not have to have
gradients at least one or they do
no they could be shrinking also usually
then you could have an interval on the
domain on the target side bi
where many different intervals end up
hitting the same interval because they
all got much shorter yeah that's correct
but the point is that these maps
are smooth so
you can take an interval of length 1
over n and blow it to an interval of say
10 over n but the degree will be still
constant
do you see what i mean
how do you get constant degree i don't
see that yeah
so you just you just have when you have
more authenticity you have weak
monotonicity you don't have strength
monotonicity in this construction so it
could be that x is less than y and they
map to the same point yeah that's
correct right but your definition of
monotonicity before was strict
monotonicity so i think that might
but yeah if a few points hit like if 10
points hit the 10 edges hit the same
point you just take 10 different edges
you just split it even more
but they're still all in the same point
yeah but they are on different
levels
but then you get more levels yes but
only a constant how do you know it's a
constant unless you bounce
you bound the derivatives they are
smooth
ah yeah they are smooth it's a compact
domain everything is like nice no way
yes
okay
so
this is why this is useful and how now i
want to explain how to build this
so how to build this continuous object
it will be similar to the schreier
diagram
from before but it will be slightly
different here the group will be
a sl2r real matrix says no
and we need to find a finite subset of
this group
and there are many choices
that could work the choice
a choice that works
is you look on these three
matrices
you look at words of constant length
say a billion in these three matrices
and
this is your the set of generators
so it's a constant subset of the group
and the action is the mobius section
it takes a point x in the interval and
wraps it to this real number
there will be no infinity in
our case
everything is close to the identity
um it doesn't really matter also but
yeah you can choose it to be smaller
and but
you need so this takes a point in zero
one and maps it to some other point and
we want to make it
the image to be 0 1 as well
so to do this we truncate this map
to be a partial map instead of being
defined over all of 0 1 we take the
pre-image of the interval 0 1
so we get a subset
of 0 1 and it became a partial map
instead of a full name
is it clear
good
so
this is the construction
and
maybe
so i will
summarize this
this gives you a continuous monotone
expander
and
as we said by this discretization
procedure we get also
discrete finite monotone expanders
and maybe some comments about this so
the first comment is that
all of the constants here are
crazy
and the the degree is very large the
expansion is very small there is no
control on these things
and another comment is that
i said that this
is a monotone expander so far we just
saw that we define a continuous map and
this action is monotone because the
mobius section is monotone
so
this is the mobius section this function
and though it's
well known that this is a monotone
map how do you prove that something is
monotone you just take derivative and
see that it's positive
and so
you just do this and because the
determinant is one
it becomes a
positive so these are all positive maps
so at least we know it's monotone but
now we also want to know why is it an
expanded
so this will be
so let's talk about why is this an
expander
so
peter sonic
thinks about it as
the proof has three steps
and he
thinks about it as three steps of a
chess game
and the reason
to
think that is that every step of the
proof has a different objective like in
every step of a chess game you have a
different
objective
and this uh
three steps these three steps
were
described by bulgan and gambo i will
state exactly the results later
who
took some
result of health got who to
and i will explain how the ideas flow
late like in the next slides
and now i want to say
in briefly what are the three steps
so the first step the opening step is to
say that locally the graph is a tree
the graph we are considered locally is a
tree it has large curve this is the
first step
the second step is
to prove something about the group
it's additive combinatorics
and the third step is to prove is to use
some mixing property of the group or in
this case of the action so these two
things will be statements on the group
and the last step
will be a statement in this case
about the action
okay in this case we will not be able to
in other cases you are able to do the
mixing property in the group itself in
this case the group is too large but the
action is nice enough that you can argue
about it and i will explain why
so these are the steps
you first show it has large girth then
you show some product growth in the
group and then you
use some property of the action
okay so
i will explain these three things now
so first large girth in this case large
girth
um
comes from what is called the tits
alternative or the effectiveness
alternative
that all of these people contributed to
and it's this statement there is a
constant num a r a number like
a thousand
so that whatever subset finite subset of
sl2r you take
if this subset
generates a group that contains sl2 z
inside s and 2 r
then in words of length r in s
r is independent of s
there are two elements in the ball
that generate a three group on two
elements okay this is the tens
alternative and the
the
key point is that r is independent of s
this is this is the effective
alternative
and
i will not say anything about the proof
of this
um except that we need the slightly
stronger version which is actually a
column what is a slightly stronger
version
it replaces the two with some number k
so
there is some constant r so that for
every k
and for every subset s as before
if we look at
words of polynomial
length
inside
in s
we can find k elements that generate a
free group
so
how can this be a cavalry of this
uh the basically i think the only way
that i would say it's a core gallery
if this argument has nothing to do with
sl2
it's just a statement about
f2
inside f2
you can find
you can do this
and
so maybe
yeah so we this is a
it's a nice way it's a nice
game to find these k elements
in the
in f2 it's not difficult
so this is the first part this is a a
deep
theorem that uses a the pin problem in
projective geometry it's it's
it's deep but do you only need this for
those specific matrices yes you're right
yeah does it require the full strength
of all of their arguments just for those
no yeah you're right they proved
something much much more general
and i think that in this specific case
even just for sl2z you can do better you
can use the
simpler argument
um
and i think uh sahih
galander has some note about this
specific case
somewhere
from this point on you just use the k
elements that
you forget about all the others
yeah i will actually not say exactly
so this is the first part i will not say
exactly
so this is the first part we found
these
k elements
maybe i want to mention that
we don't know what are these k elements
what i wrote here is
like
abstract thing
if we want this to be explicit what do
we do we just take all of these k to the
other things
we don't
pick them in a clever way and they just
make it even more expanding
um
so in the choices we take all of these
things
in the proof we argue just about this
these k things that we do not know what
they are
um
so this is the first part
the second part is a product growth in
the group
and
this is the slide i will have on this
so
it says that uh
if you choose a subset a of sl2r
and
this subset should satisfy some
technical conditions
and that i will not talk about it has to
have some
nice behavior in many scales
then if you multiply a by a
by a three times you pick three random
elements of a and multiply them
this set becomes larger
than a and the way to measure size in
this is the metric entropy
um so
this is the main
technical part
of
the proof
uh to prove this for sl2r
but this
continues a
very fruitful line of work
that has two
parallels one is in the finite field
case
um that started with the sum product
theorem
then a
work of health got and then burgundy
made these three steps that
we call chess game
and they also
there is also a continuous real analog
of this where the sun product theorem
becomes
this theorem it's a theorem though it's
called the conjecture
and
then they use this to prove expansion
inside su-2
the main difference is that this group
is compact it makes things easier and
sl2r is not compact so there are more
technicalities to take care of
so this is the second part
the product growth part
and the third part
discusses the action
and i will not say exactly
in the real case what happens i will
give an example in the finite case which
is
uh contains every all the ideas so here
assume that g is a finite group and it
acts on a finite set x
this the mixing property
is
what is written here
you can think about mu as being a
probability measure on g
and of a f as a
vector that is orthogonal to the all one
vector
on x so mu is on g f is on x
then you can look what happens when you
convolve mu
and f
so you take averages
you f of x is the average with respect
to the action
so this is the formal
definition of convolution and the
requirement is that the convolution
its toner decreases
if you remove the n this is kushi
schwarz inequality
and what this property tells you that
you gain over kushish votes
if n is large so this is useful when n
is large
okay so mixing property is this property
and it's useful when n is large what is
that
and
determines how good is the mixing
property it's unspecified yes
um
and this was used in many works this
idea so this is a short summary of the
definition
so it was used in all of these things
all of these works and also
when david talked he also mentioned this
um
so this property holds when the group we
look at
has only large dimensional irreducible
representations
this is one example when this property
holds
another example where this property
holds and it's actually simpler to argue
somehow is that if the action we look at
is just too transitive
so it's a
it
doesn't talk about
representations at all we just look on
the action and we require it to be too
transitive
and this is a
it's fairly simple to do this you do
you do kushish varus once and it just
happens
um
and
in this case we are very happy because
the mobius section that we used is
actually three transitive so
we are able to perform this
step to argue
and
this because the centaur is not compact
it it also becomes messy but this is the
basic idea
so this is the third step
you use that the mirror with action is
three transitive
okay
can you say what you achieve at the end
of each step i mean is there some
yeah i have a
i wanted to discuss it but i think i
prefer to mention an open problem and
then also running i can it's not
complicated i can tell
so these are
just ideas and ideas on the proof so
here is what we said so far
there are simple expanders in this sense
there are monotone and also constant
page
and to prove it we
used many things
and we discuss this at least in some
detail
and i want to mention some other one
question that is
related to this so this is the last
slide
so here is the question i want to
the question is are there even simpler
expanders simpler even monotone
expanders
so here is a natural candidate for
building an expander a graph so
so
the graph will have
a the left side both sides will be the
numbers from one to n from zero to n
minus one
and we map
a number x
to a number a i x plus b i
but this number may not be integer so we
first round it to an integer and then
take modulo n
okay so
this is a map from
0 to n minus 1 to 0 to n minus 1 and we
can ask ourselves
can we build expanders using such simple
maps just a fine
maps
and what clever proved is that if we
just use here rational numbers
then we cannot build expanded graphs
and i want to
mention that
these when you act with rational numbers
here it's not an action
of it's not an action there is
one half times x
it's not x over two in zn
it's something completely different or
it may be completely different
so
these maps are not do not fit into the
action
uh area
what would you mean divide by two is not
the same
if you
say take all of the
computations
it's one third instead of
so this is
one over three
this is one
and three
inverse modulu n
this is a different number
so
the eis and bis are fixed and the
families are then varying
yes here
we choose
a i and bi to be
first we choose a constant number of
rationals and then we try to make use
them to be
an infinite family
and what is the reason that this theorem
holds it's a simple reason
and
the reason is that
the one-dimensional fan group is
solvable
so this basically holds for all solvable
groups
but only for rationals
and the main question is that
is very interesting they think is what
happens for real coefficients
can we build expanders using such
schemes
when the coefficients are in instead of
rationals it seems like a very subtle
like
why should it matter
um
so i want to mention two things one is
you can make here
the statement of gravity a bit more
general
and this uses diaphone approximation
very simple diaphragm approximation
but it also
sort of shows why r is interesting
because you need to really
control
the behavior
and another comment that if you replace
solvability by polynomial growth which
is a weaker condition or stronger
it depends
so every group that has polynomial
yeah yeah
yes
and
so if you try to do it
with
real groups of polynomial groups not
rational real groups of polynomial group
like the heisenberg group or some other
thing
then you can also not build expanders
and
this is a
it's
simple it's not so for polynomial groups
polynomial groups this doesn't work but
for solvable groups we i don't know if
it works and any proof of it will should
distinguish between r and q
inside like
should use something more from
something
more deep or i don't know how to phrase
it so i thank you for this attention
yes can you say now what you're trying
to achieve at the end of each phase
and
so
i can
try
so
and let's ignore that this is a
continuous space
let's just think it's fine so in the
first step we just
argue that the graph locally
looks like a tree
so this is step one
so we start with a
a random we start a random work from a
point and see what happens to it
so
at the in this time it behaves perfectly
because it's an expanded
now
we reached a fairly large subset of the
of the graph
from here onwards
this set
when you multiply it by itself three
times you get a larger set
so
multiplying itself by itself three times
corresponds to
taking this three three times these
three is defined by s
this
so after
a constant number of steps
we reach
a very large part of the graph
almost all the graph so this is part two
in
applying
squaring a constant number of times we
reach
even not like n to the x
here we have we have a size one
here we are
of small size
basically everything
and from here onwards to get to the
whole graph
this is the mixing
this you
get from controlling the convolution so
in one more steps you get uniform
this is a rough idea
i hope it was somehow clear
just remove the leftmost portion of the
internet so you just want to get n o 2
up to n to expand
under maps of the form
integer part of aix
if you allow
just if you want to focus on the left
part it's easy yes because it's also in
the
if you
look on the map
x
maps to 2x it's an expanding map
so
it's expanding here but here there will
be something that doesn't expand
so now the whole point is
yeah you need to take care of the whole
thing
this is somehow related to what happens
after you make this map unitary when you
divide by the derivative and
in the group language
avi and they have have
an iterative construction in the zigzag
flavor
and it works except that the
you need a something to start from
and the only thing we know to start from
is this thing
so
actually after you know this thing
exists you just look
inside the graph say you want to
construct a graph of size n
you look in graphs of size log log login
something like this you find the best
graph there is then you use zigzag and
you get
everything right so yeah so you can
start from scratch
you want
but
yeah it's a problem like
you need to know that there is an
infinite a dense enough infinite family
of these graphs
thank
you you